a mother prepares to bury her daughter
arzoo a soy and her 15 year old
granddaughter yamour
they were among the victims of Sunday's
bombing in the heart of Istanbul an
attack authorities blame on the outlawed
Kurdistan Workers Party or the pkk
IE
the last time I saw her was on Friday we
had plans I don't know what else to say
it was here where the suspect a woman is
believed to have left a bomb that
exploded in Istanbul's busiest Street
this Declan is a major tourist
attraction and many fear the target was
chosen to cause fear and instability
I am worried tourists will stop coming
and I'm also worried about our safety my
wife tells me not to go to work but how
long can I stay home
police say they have detained dozens
including the woman whom they identified
as Bashir
the interior Ministry says she came from
Syria where she was trained by the ypg
the Syrian Kurdish Group which turkey
considers as an offshoot of the pkk
IES
we got their message and I want them to
know that we will respond to this in a
very strong manner
the pkk which has claimed some attacks
in the past has denied the accusations
there was a time when attacks similar to
Sundays happen frequently from 2015
until the last major violent incident
nearly five years ago is the Cloud
street was also among the targets
that attack was blamed on isil Fighters
but many here say it's the military's
recent operations against the pkk in
Northern Iraq and Northern Syria that
may have been the reason for Sunday's
explosion
the timing of the attack also months
before a general election the government
is already under pressure from the worst
cost of living crisis in decades it now
is faced with a security challenge
Istanbul